let's go next - I've got someone from
the 202 area code we didn't get your
name last time you called but I have you
as funny anti Biden guy does that ring a
bell do you know who this is
yeah that's here that's what was your
name
yeah funny story and this okay about a
while ago I mean I think the first time
I call was about like the the debate
that Kyle had was like do razors and I
was to do who said that that was like a
political awakening for me okay okay and
what was your name yeah my name is Tommy
he said you said now I'm Barbie downs
good caller but then the next time I
call you like this caller but I guess
you I don't know what's his name it's
out like where do you not remember me
Wow now I'm gonna make absolutely sure
that we have you labeled in ful fully
accurately yeah so there were several
things that was like running through my
mind recently occurs like sometimes are
just like I'm over some stuff there's
like so I can he talks in lie about this
political thing sure not to say people
really I think are that type of informed
just to say that one thing that was kind
of going through my mind around it this
is partly me not doing as much research
as I would like to do it was like a the
idea of Obama is okay
I remember call reading some here on
some force that said that he had like a
90 percent like civilian casualty rate
or something that's highs that when it
came to like him escalating with drone
strikes okay was like over speeds up
what and I was like you know a lot of
these things you create you will say
that we need to like basically indict
lockup I know it's never gonna happen
but me to indict will lock up George
Bush because of his war crimes right I'm
like being hypocrites for not saying the
same thing about Obama listen I mean
ever every president kills people
foreign policy that's a reality and I
mean you know we can take one view which
is they should all be locked up as war
criminals we could take the view that
that doesn't really make sense because
then you know there are many many many
presidents and prime ministers who but
by that standard are war criminals and
it and we sort of have to operate I mean
it's it's it's disappointing but we have
to operate with a different barometer I
guess I would say which sounds
absolutely insane to say but this is
sort of the state of the world affairs
in 2019 but I completely understand what
you're saying every president you know
this idea of Hillary was going to be
Killary and he'll kill all these people
every president through foreign policy
makes decisions that lead to deaths that
would otherwise not happen now maybe
other people would die if they didn't
make those decisions but this is a real
complex issue right thing is like and
the only thing that I would say is that
sorry I got a bit of a cold the other
thing I would say is probably like oh
but uh but I just lost my train of
thought hello Tommy oh it seems like
Tommy bailed when he lost his train of
thought that's weird okay all right well
Tommy thank you for the call and we hope
to hear from you again let's take a
quick break don't hang up if you're
holding because we will go immediately
back to the phones right after this
short break